- I'm definitely gonna
get diabetes after this.
(jazz music)
- When I think of American cereal
I just think of sugar. Just plain sugar.
- I'm so excited to try these,
I've been waiting years for this.
- I'm ready.
- Yup, let's do this.
- Cap'n? What happened to the "tain"?
Captain.
- It's cap'n. Cap'n Crunch.
- Doesn't smell like anything.
- It's weirdly boring.
- It's, like, glazed with sugar,
which I find is awesome.
- They really do taste like Cheerios.
- This kind of reminds me of
when I was a kid and had Cornflakes,
you would put the sugar on.
But with this you need
to take some sugar out.
This isn't cereal. These are cookies.
- Why did you give me cookies in a bowl?
- Not bad.
- It doesn't really taste
like a cookie, though.
- This is Nutrigrain but it's got
chocolate chip cookies in it.
- No need to give Santa
a big glass of milk
and a giant cookie.
Instead just give him a bowl of this.
- I'm not a fan.
- See, I think America was
just running out of ideas.
They just chucked a
bunch of cookies in a box
and called it cereal.
- I'm not a big fan of
Reese's peanut butter cups.
That's too intense.
- And now it's in a cereal.
- (laughs)
- These look like giant Coco Puffs.
- They remind me of pet food.
- Or rabbit poo.
- It tastes so good, but I
think I shouldn't like it.
- This is like a hollow Kit Kat.
- I like peanut butter but I don't think
it belongs in cereal.
- This is like a sad cereal.
- I'd probably have this after a breakup.
- So can I take this box home with me?
Cause, I'm, I'm done.
I've never heard of this before.
What is Cinnamon Toast Crunch?
- These look like Grain Waves.
- You can actually smell the cinnamon.
- Tastes like Christmas.
- Cinnamon scrolls at
Cole's that you can buy.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- It tastes exactly like cinnamon toast
which is awesome and
then it's mixed with milk
and just makes it even better.
- Mm, so good.
- I expected doughnuts,
these are not doughnuts.
- These are better than doughnuts.
- Now there's something good
about how simple this is.
I appreciate that.
- I would happily move to America
just for Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
- Trix are for kids.
- I don't understand why I have a rainbow
in my bowl.
- All I thought was Nerds in milk.
- This is like Froot Loops but on crack.
- Hands down I could
buy this for breakfast.
I could buy this lunch and dinner as well.
- Would you have this again?
- Um, no, no, I wouldn't.
- Mr. Prime Minister?
Get these on our shelves, right now.
- Lucky Charms!
- Is that marshmallow in there?
- Why do you have
marshmallows in your cereal?
- Yeah, that's just weird America.
- It's one of those cereals
that you put in the cart
and your mom says, "Get it out."
- Yeah.
- (laughs)
- Oh! It's so slimy, too.
- Oh, no.
- Yeah, no. I'm good. I'm done.
- This is more of a
dessert than a breakfast.
- The marshmallows in the Lucky Charms
are like the Beyonce in Destiny's Child,
take them away and it's nothing.
- The cereal isn't the greatest
but I know it means well because, hey,
there's rainbows in here
so it's progressive.
- After today, I think American cereal
was exactly what I thought it was:
colorful, sugary, and diabetes.
- America you've set the
bar for out-there cereals
and the rest of the world
has a lot to live up to.
- I'm on the sugar rush
of my life right now
so, thank you for that, America.
- I feel as if Australian
cereal is Lil' Wayne
but American cereal is Jay-Z.